muitas vezes a gente não se pergunta
quando vai fazer alguma coisa
o real motivo pelo qual a gente está
desenvolvendo essa ação para começar a
minha fala eu gostaria de 1º estabelecer
isso porque não bem aqui sozinha
eu vim aqui para falar de heróis de
pessoas que eu conheci de situações que
eu vivenciei de lugares que eu passei
e tudo isso tem alguma forma me
acompanha
está aqui agora presente então que isso
que eu venho falar agora com vocês possa
nesse momento nesse lugar 7 benefício
tanto para nós quanto para qualquer
pessoa que venha a tomar contato com
isso e qualquer coisa de positivo
qualquer coisa de construtivo que eu
tiver pra falar agora pra vocês aqui
ela também não vem de mim
ela também é fruto das incontáveis
fontes de ensinamento que eu tive das
pessoas com quem me relacionei os quais
considero todos invariavelmente os
professores e os erros de alguma forma
são meus agora aqui durante a nossa
estadia em katmandu no nepal
eu tive a oportunidade de receber muitas
coisas preciosíssimas isso não se
relaciona apenas a estadia dentro do
ministério isso se relaciona
principalmente as relações que foram
instituídas
uma das principais foi a transmissão do
texto de um monge indiano
chamado gente deva nesse texto gente
deva ele coloca uma coisa extremamente
integrante e contraditória a nossa mente
toda a felicidade
desculpem todo sofrimento no mundo tem
de buscar a felicidade para si mesmo
toda felicidade do mundo vem de buscar
propiciar felicidade para os demais
essa situação
ela sempre me marcou muito e ao mesmo
tempo pra nossa mente ela é extremamente
contraditória como em seu como que eu
vou conseguir ser feliz buscando uma
felicidade externa para outras pessoas
para tentar explicar um pouco como que
isso pode ser possível eu resolvi trazer
três conceitos simples
o primeiro é tempo o segundo é
experiência mas principalmente o
heroísmo
o conceito de herói
esses conceitos esses três conceitos
eles são na cultura indiana e muito
especificamente na cultura budista
tibetano na qual eu tenho um contato
muito diferentes dos conceitos que a
gente nutre no decorrer da nossa vida no
ocidente a gente tem uma idéia de tempo
linear uma teologia da história que a
gente tenta colocar um sentido em linha
reta a todas as coisas que a gente faz a
nossa experiência é como a experiência
que eu tenho agora aquele palco de
sujeito e objeto o que causa um
estranhamento porque nessa perspectiva
ocidental
eu estou separado de você de alguma
forma nessa perspectiva em que
os filhos de um mecanismo europeu a
gente de alguma forma mantém por mais
que a gente registado e o conceito do
herói diferente por exemplo do conceito
do marketing
o herói hollywood ano é aquele que
sobrevive no final do filme é aquele que
consegue passar por determinada situação
não necessariamente ileso mas ele
triunfar sobre a morte porque nós temos
muito medo dela
a cultura ocidental geral têm muito medo
dela na cultura indiana na
especificamente na cultura budista a
gente tem um conceito um pouco diferente
o tempo ele deve ser transmitido ele
pode ser transferido a relação que se
estabelece na experiência é uma relação
que forma uma espécie de mandala todos
têm um mente a idéia da mandala primeira
imagem que eu mostrei os monges
tibetanos fazendo mandalas de areia
a idéia da mandala é que ela se torne um
mapa tridimensional do palácio
tridimensional da experiência
todos os meus sentidos ea relação
interdependente que eu tenho com as
circunstâncias formam ao redor de mim
formam no meu fluxo mental
uma mandava brilhante e colorida de
experiências
a experiência então nessa cultura é
interdependente
é uma experiência que é construída todo
momento junto com minha própria
identidade
eu me construa a partir de vocês e o
herói não é aquele que sobrevive até o
final
pelo contrário o herói daquele que morre
e torna incessantemente para suprimir
para diminuir o sofrimento dessa
interdependência essa insatisfatória
idade
da existência na cultura indiana
tudo o que a gente percebe dentro dessa
mandala todos os movimentos que a gente
faz no mundo
qualquer jornada que a gente aprenda
ela também tem um caráter heróico mas há
um sentido que existe uma jornada de um
herói não o herói
nesse contexto ele é despersonalizado o
herói
ele não é uma pessoa que chega pra te
salvar de alguma coisa nesse contexto
toda a experiência é uma espécie de
herói
toda a experiência quando é vivida de
maneira consciente é um herói que
arranca debaixo dos escombros de uma
tragédia
a nossa pronta iluminação nossa própria
consciência do momento presente
essa construção da experiência
essa idéia de herói é caracterizada por
gente deva como o espírito de um bom
dentro da cultura budista indiana e das
diversas culturas budistas ao redor do
mundo
ele é uma pessoa que faz o voto de
alguma forma como eu falei retornar
sempre a todo momento pra salvar a nossa
própria consciência
cada coisa que a gente vivencia vai
formando nesse sentido a nossa mandala
de experiência por exemplo a nossa
jornada que começou em 2014
passando por vários lugares na índia
lá daqui do nepal a cada momento em que
nós caminhávamos por tempos antigos por
cavernas vales por campos cheios de
frutas pelo quando qualquer sentido quer
aguçado por exemplo doce dos abricós lá
dá tudo isso ea formando de alguma forma
essa mandala colorida a cada momento em
que a gente chegava em uma casa humilde
em um templo antigo a forma com que a
gente caminhava por aquele lugar era
mais uma linha colocada nesse desenho
que o próprio desenho da experiência a
cada vaga agente caminhava cada montanha
que a gente via os lugares maravilhosos
em que a gente tinha oportunidade de
sentar e por um momento simplesmente não
fazer nada e adicionando de alguma forma
essas cores
essas coisas no budismo tibetano as
telas estão relacionados a melhorias
muito específica muito específica sobre
como a gente deve lidar com a própria
experiência e ela estão fora do tempo
elas aparecem a todo momento e elas
acabam colorindo a forma com que a gente
observa
aquilo que seria a realidade exterior
cada uma dessas cores que compõem a
mandala da minha experiência ela é uma
sabedoria específica nesse sentido o
caminho a jornada é a própria sabedoria
de buda é o próprio smo é a própria
manifestação desses heróis desse
esgotados
quando eu falo que eu não vim aqui
sozinho
eu realmente não vim porque o meu
principal objetivo é falar dos heróis
que conheci
das pessoas dos lugares e quando eu digo
que não são só pessoas
eu quero me referir a inclusive um
conceito que vem da tradição budista que
esse tipo de herói ele não precisa ser
necessariamente corporificado a idéia do
jeito que é diferente
esse herói inclusive buda e nas
histórias contadas pela tradição eles se
manifestavam como animais eles se
manifestavam como lugares se manifestar
inclusive como objetos sagrados para
transmitir um determinado ensinamento e
quando digo transmitir é o próprio
processo de como a gente cria essa
narrativa ea gente estará em
ensinamentos da jornada a jornada numa
viagem pode ser uma viagem à índia o
nepal mas ela pode ser também uma viagem
para visitar seus pais no interior essa
mandala formada pela jornada
no caso da nossa jornada entre índia e
até acabando
ela sofreu como as mandalas dos monges
tibetanos uma destruição uma quebra
bruta durante o grande terremoto de 2015
então foi como se todas aquelas
experiências que haviam sido construídas
na mandala elas se desfizessem com uma
mão passando por cima
e essa é uma característica de toda a
experiência as mandalas de experiência
ela se criam e ela se destroem a todo
momento a todo momento um momento de
crise porque nós reconstruímos aquilo
que a gente vê aquilo que a gente é a
gente passa por tremores constantes da
nossa existência
eu conheci muitos heróis em katmandu e
eu acredito que a característica
principal do herói é a presença
o fato de você está presente não é
necessariamente de você conseguir
superar alguma coisa mas você está
presente eu tinha colegas que não tinham
não possui nenhum recurso não eram nada
para ajudar
mas o terremoto quando tinha 3 milhões
de desabrigados e as ruas da cidade
depois do terremoto eram cheias de casas
de luanda três milhões de desabrigados
ea população da cidade de porto alegre
então vocês imaginem o ambiente e nesses
ambientes onde o caos ea confusão reina
a gente começa a perceber pequenos
pontos
e esses pequenos pontos começa a fazer
sentido para a experiência
esses pequenos pontos é o que eu chamo
de heróis
eles começam a criar uma nova mandala a
partir daquela mesma areia colorida que
foi misturada no fim esses heróis eles
atuam com não um objetivo específico mas
com duas armas e tradicionalmente são
chamadas sabedoria e compaixão e eles
como eu falei não sendo pessoas
necessariamente físicas uma situação
pode te mostrar sabedoria compaixão um
animal quando chega quando você chega
depois o trabalho em casa e disse ana
ele pode ser o herói daquele dia
os heróis são caracterizados então por
isso pela presença
eles são caracterizados por essa
sabedoria que reconhece a experiência
sendo criada a todo momento a todo
instante
esses heróis eles estão sempre presentes
nos nossos momentos de crise
por mais que a gente acredite que eles
não estão lá eu conheci um monte de
betânia em dançar foi aprisionado pelos
chineses e depois que ele foi liberado
atravessando a fronteira pra índia e ele
acabou trabalhando na
linhas de trem é só um é e ele sempre
reconheceu a sabedoria ea compaixão dos
momentos não é então uma questão de
pieguice
não é uma questão de aparentar alguma
coisa e não é sequer de se preocupar com
o que os outros vão pensar de tite a
observar essa bondade nata em todas as
coisas que acontecem na vida que
consegui perceber esses heróis se
manifestando
é um ato de coragem e isso junto com a
presença também caracteriza o que é um
herói
a mandala a nossa em cima sempre
recomeça a gente tá todo momento sujeito
a todo tipo de tremor
a nossa existência mas nós nos
reconstruímos de alguma forma nós
reconstruímos a mandala da experiência
o importante é manter a consciência
dessa construção e por perceber que não
existe diferença nenhuma entre você ea
mandala que está sendo criada de forma
interdependente com tudo aquilo que você
esperiência que isso eu chamo de
sabedoria
você acaba desenvolvendo a compaixão a
empatia
quando eu digo que eu vim aqui falar por
todas as pessoas que ficaram para trás
eu falo de todas as pessoas que durante
o terremoto dormiram em barracas de lona
todas as pessoas que morreram todas as
pessoas que de alguma forma logo após o
terremoto em que eu pessoalmente me
sentir como um sobrevivente de guerra e
me sentir como indigno de estar naquele
momento mas eu percebi que isso é uma
visão errada daquilo que eu era como um
sujeito porque eu realmente não estava
sozinho
e se a mandala da nossa jornada inicial
se desfez com o terremoto
eu percebi que esses heróis a todo
momento eles nos salvam desses escombros
da nossa confusão e a mandala recomeça
seja pra mim seja pra você seja um país
inteiro
a mandala sempre comércio independente
das circunstâncias em uma prisão chinesa
no terremoto em casa mandou dentro do
escritório
ao final
gostaria de dedicar isso também a todas
essas pessoas ea todas as pessoas que de
alguma forma tiveram contato com essa
fala e que se alguma coisa deve ficar
isso sabedoria e compaixão presença e
coragem são o verdadeiro smu